called for a speedy trial so they said
October 23rd and they agreed a judge
confirmed yeah they said they wanted
Trump to go in uh March 4th Willis
proposed the trial should start for all
19 defendants on March 4th 2024. wow
yeah Trump's team is going to fight that
and be like we need more time to prepare
go over to Discovery right they're gonna
they're gonna file it they're going to
file extensions there's there's no way I
don't even know why Trump went to
Georgia in the first place
uh Force Joe Biden to send Federal
Marshals to extradite Trump from New
Jersey or Florida Florida's a better bet
because New Jersey would they didn't
extradite Trump in two seconds but if
Trump went to Florida and said whatever
charges may arise out of uh he went to
Florida and said any charges arising and
right next to Georgia by the way are
rising out of Georgia they can send the
legal paper paperwork to my house serve
me proper legal service for which I will
respond but the idea that you can go on
the TV and claim I have to surrender is
not legal service then what would happen
is they'd have to contact what Florida
right Georgia would have to ask law
enforcement in Florida to apprehend an
extradite Donald Trump so I'll tell you
how it would go so um because I've done
this I've seen this happen before so if
you are a fugitive from Justice and
you're out of state and they know that
you're out of state or they can no
longer fulfill that warrant what they're
going to do is they're going to delegate
that warrant to the United States
Marshal Service once the United States
Marshal Service gets the warrant now
they're responsible for going to go get
them so they would probably coordinate
with the Secret Service Hey where's he
at we have to we have to you know we
have to execute the rest this arrest
warrant that we have from the state of
Georgia Georgia and they would bring him
in now knowing Jack Smith and how he is
they would probably also get something
out of Atlanta out of the the I think
it's the Northern District of Georgia or
whatever the federal prosecutor's office
over there in Fulton County they would
probably apply for something called the
ufap warrant which is an unlawful flight
to avoid prosecution warrant and they
would hit him with another Federal
charge because they know that he's
indicted and he's not showing up that's
after legal service
I mean I mean he's been indicted by a
grand jury man like all right and so
they the government can't just go on TV
and say uh you know those guys from
fresh and fit they they got 10 days to
go to jail because we said so you'd be
like what send me the legal paperwork
requesting my like get they have a true
bill that's all they need so so without
legal notice they can claim your
refugitive without even telling you
they have a true bill of indictment and
they're telling them that he's wanted no
no I'm saying legal service requires
they tell Trump that he's wanted
they said you need to surrender right
right my point is going on TV is not
proper legal service
like if I if I go on TV announce I'm
suing someone
they don't have to do anything and then
if the if I if I never give them the
paperwork they're gonna be like your
honor like going on TV and claiming a
legal thing does not make a legal
service I agree improper serve but I
mean a criminal case I mean
realistically speaking when that
whenever they indict you right they too
they do it surreptitiously they get an
arrest warrant from the clerk and then
they go pick you up so that you don't
know you're gonna being picked up so in
this case they would just say well we
indicted you we have a true we have a
true bill uh here's it here it is so the
marshals would have to come to Florida
and say Trump you are hereby under
arrest for for a warrant in Georgia and
then assuming he doesn't surrender then
they would have to delegate Marshalls
yeah Donald Trump should have gone to
Florida and said deliver me proper
service
oh
I don't know man I I think I think he
did the good thing by surrendering
because if he had done that right then
Georgia would be like okay cool we're
not only are we gonna file a ufat warn
against you so now you're going to get
another Federal charge yep uh now the
marshes are gonna go get you and it's
going to be a problem so and then Rhonda
Santos would have to be like we're gonna
let him come in and just take Trump from
his home it's no big deal and then there
would be chaos in Bedlam make them
follow up with their threats if there's
like these charges against Trump out of
Georgia are psychotic and insane they're
stupid yeah you want to make it you make
an argument about and and all I'm saying
is that Trump should make them follow
the law like the idea that Trump would
take the extra effort to seek them out
when they are accusing him doesn't make
sense to me hmm
if if the police like
no but they have an arrest warrant for
him and so I'm saying go deliver the
warrants go to his house next door
here's your reward okay take me we're
going to Georgia the idea that Trump
contacted them and was like I I heard on
the TV that you have a warp formation to
come in makes no sense to me he should
be like come knock on my door tell me
that you have a warrant or or or in some
way initiate that through a legal
process I'm sure they probably fax the
warrant to his legal team you know
signed by a judge they they I guarantee
you they gave that to they faxed it to
his team and let him know and the other
reason too why they announced is that so
he's put on notice he can make because
you gotta remember he's the president
United States a former president United
States they got a coordinate with Secret
Service you got 10 days to surrender Etc
so they have to do all this logistical
stuff but typically you're never
notified that you're being under arrest
because they're gonna come get you and
then they're gonna oh yeah we have
warrant for your arrest I'm saying Trump
should have had that happen he should
have had them just follow the proper
legal protocol for coming and arresting
him
oh no but I mean they're going to give
him the common courtesy and then he's
with the Secret Service right I don't
think any of us are served properly by
Donald Trump proactively seeking out his
political persecution unless unless it's
to just fundraise and he knows it's not
going to matter and they wanted to make
a media because meet a spectacle about
it and so I I think the the proper thing
is let them serve their warrant
like go arrest them you like go
physically actually go try to go get
them it's it's not like he's fleeing
he's in his house they knock on his door
like what they do with Roger Stone and
they say Donald Trump you're under
arrest and he goes okay and he gets in
the car and they go to Georgia
that's what they do
Roger Stone wasn't contacted and told to
go show up at their course they went to
his house Trump should have said
I'm here I'm waiting serve me the
warrant I got no issues we will
absolutely abide by the terms it's it's
I don't understand why it's incumbent
upon him to proactively seek out his
surrender in another state when they
haven't served him they've done it
they've done it in all the cases though
every time they indicted trumpet Trump
and all of his allies are surrendering
and giving in and giving them everything
they want my point is what position
would this country be in if Federal
Marshals were forced to go arrest the
former president in his own home and
Rhonda said is the governor governor of
Florida agreed to allow it to happen
there's a certain point where if Trump
as the former president says this stops
like like not posting Bond call there
Bluff say are you really intending a
political persecution and prosecution of
a former president then you will go by
the legal you'll go by the book you will
take the warrant you will get it signed
off and you will come and make the
arrest
Trump giving them what they want and
calling him up the photo back I'll come
okay here's other reasons too well
here's the other reason too I see I see
your perspective but the other reason as
well is that they can go ahead and say
okay well you don't want to show up well
we're going to remand you into custody
yes 100 yeah so and you're saying that
let them end into custody and everything
else like that but he wants to run bro
he wants to go around and campaign and
everything else like that so he's
looking at it like all right I'm going
to cooperate right because they're
already trying to paint him as you
started the January six riots even
though he said you know you know protest
peacefully but everyone's the left tends
to forget that that he said protest
peacefully but whatever so in his eyes
he's like all right I'm gonna go ahead
go through the motion I'm gonna
surrender I'm gonna abide by the law
then I'm gonna get out and do what I got
to do but I think for him he's looking
at it like if I don't surrender they're
gonna probably remind me in the custody
I won't be able to Campaign which would
be a nightmare for them to remind them
in custody I don't think they would
you could call the bluff yeah that's
that that's a possibility on you on that
the big problem that I see especially
with the right in this country is
capitulation every step of the way the
reasonableness the desire to be
reasonable and not engage
you're playing a game of Monopoly you're
watching the dude you're playing against
pull bills out of the bank and you go
hey man you're cheating and they go no
I'm allowed to do it and you go okay
and then you lose you go man how did I
lose that's what they're doing it's also
as lawyers too that are probably because
I guarantee you Trump is probably like
well you know what no I don't want to
show but his lawyers is on him hey man
you got to show up like let's just get
this done let's do this peacefully Etc
so you can keep campaigning and so what
happens is every day a grain of sand is
added to the Heap yeah and as the a
better analogy is frogs in a pot boiling
as the temperature increases by one
degree every day the frogs isn't
actually not a true soy frogs do notice
but the analogy as it goes if you if you
put frogs in a Boiling Pot they jump out
if you put them in water and slowly turn
the temperature up they just boil to
death yeah because they don't realize
temperature is changing it's actually
not true if the temperature gets too hot
the frogs will just literally jump out
you know
the stories are more fun but that's what
I'm saying like no it's I mean
there's got to be some degree of Donald
Trump
at the very least providing the legal
the legal minimum of some kind of
restraint or resistance in
if you guys have a warrant for my arrest
you have my address and I will gladly I
will gladly without resistance right
just go with you when you come to pick
me up Trump paid how much does it cost
to fly that jet 50 Grand Trump paid 50
000 to go to surrender for them
it's a path of least resistance the
other thing too you got to remember is
that when a warrant's put out for
someone and they're a uh there's a
felony warrant out for them Secret
Service is still law enforcement that's
right and I'd like I'd like to see the
Secret Service cuff Donald Trump and
bring him to a van and that's something
the American people should see that's
crazy they're like this is awkward yeah
yeah they're like yeah because
technically because if you look at any
any whether it's a federal state warrant
it says to any peace officer and or
officer of the United States most
warrants are written like that to some
random some kind of language like that
secret service is technically sworn law
enforcement so it's like it gets tricky
man it gets very very true leftists are
willing to take to engage in a wide
range of tactics from non-violent Civil
Disobedience which I think is the
I think is the most effective and
reasonable tool for political change
generating awareness being obstructive
but not engaging in like overt acts of
violence and like you know no danger I'm
talking about they will sit down on the
street piss people off it's super
annoying and then they'll get arrested
for it I find it really annoying but I
think that's the right way to go about
things some stress on the system but
nobody gets hurt however the left is
also willing to firebomb buildings yep
pull out guns shoot and kill people
Donald Trump's not even willing to say
please serve the warrant and I will
gladly be arrested he's saying I will
pay 50 000 to get on a plane and go fly
to you so you can arrest me and I'm just
like man and put up a 200 000 Bond yeah
20 grand yeah 20 grand 10 but so but but
I will say to be fair
this is just more of a what I'm really
saying is where is any degree of passive
resistance
and I don't want to impose upon I don't
want to imply I know their legal
strategy better
I think there's probably a reason Trump
went about doing this yeah yeah I think
he's his legal team is telling him to do
this but I think it's a political team
too yeah I think his political team is
saying the amount of money you're going
to make off of this will absolutely be
worth the trip the amount like the
campaign will cover the cost of flying
the plane for you to go you know
probably can't do it that way legally
but like the amount of money that you
make in selling merch the merch drop
he's like he doesn't get to play in the
merch and here's another thing too you
gotta remember like it's very obvious
that there the media is willing to twist
and contort Trump's words to make him
sound like an insurrectionist so it's
like by him not surrendering and not
complying they're gonna say look look we
told you he's an anarchist he doesn't
care about the United States January 6
blah blah blah blah so it's like in his
head he's like okay the legal I'm
running for president I don't want to
put off an idea that I'm an
insurrectionist even though I'm not but
the media the media is against them you
look at MSNBC CNN all these guys they're
all vilifying him and I'm like that's
not true that's not what he said but
they do that right to make him look
crazy so in his head he's like all right
I need to surrender and I and even
though he could you know say oh you guys
come get me they could look at that as
like oh look we told you guys on order
guys out here not obeying yeah exactly
so it's that's not an optic situation it
could look bad too I I agree with that
yeah but I'm not saying he should do
anything illegal I'm saying he should
just say you know like I am ready and
willing to respond to anyone come get me
do your jobs
media would twist it anyways and the
average person who's only paying
attention and I'm saying this that Trump
refuses to surrender I'm saying this
that I think that the best route for him
for him surrendering because I'm looking
at it from an optic standpoint like from
a law enforcement standpoint I know how
the judges are I know what they might
how they might look at as as they might
remand them to custody I want him to win
I'm gonna vote for him I don't care I'm
putting it out there but I want him to
be able to run and be able to campaign
and win and beat these isn't it
telling that his uh well co-conspirator
so to speak are smiling in their
mugshots it's kind of like maybe they
know something that we don't know but I
don't know if it's that they know
something that we don't know they know
that it's BS charges yeah they they know
they know like you're really going ahead
and indicting his lawyers in this
situation
yeah you guys are reaching you know and
again the state so at the state level
they're okay with putting ridiculous
charges on people to get immediate media
spectacle because the state doesn't care
if they lose cases the State loses cases
all the time it's a U.S attorney's
office that cares about winning cases
which is why I'm more concerned with the
federal charges that Jack Smith is
bringing against Trump versus these
State charges what does it mean for
America if he's convicted you said uh
Anarchy a little bit not Anarchy Anarchy
is is uh in in Anarchy in the truest and
purest sense
is just no Authority it doesn't imply
chaos or or violence or anything like
that it could literally be a bunch of
people sitting around sharing
a peace pipe you know what I mean uh
conflict active conflict between
factions and
uh uh social disorder social breakdown
so
I do think a component could be civil
war
we are likely in a period of civil
Strife right now
uh I often quote Stephen Marshall wrote
the book and studied this
um this is a period where typically
occurs before Civil Wars where a certain
number of people are killed every year
for political reasons and the U.S
qualifies there's a lot of people don't
realize how many people are killed every
year over some kind of political or
ideological issue yeah if Donald Trump
is convicted or if he's removed from one
state
look we also have it on January 6th
they've got people locked up in DC who
have not been charged with any crime do
you guys know that yes oh yeah I mean
I've talked about the January 6th stuff
as well a lot of those people most of
them were charged with a BS misdemeanor
man and they're incredible a year in
jail because they walked around confused
the bureau went ahead and wasted a bunch
of resources in time normally federal
agencies are not supposed to investigate
misdemeanors but they expended a
ridiculous amount of resources to go
after guys right for misdemeanors if you
read those criminal complaints a lot of
them are misdemeanors what do you think
happens when you got the Capitol Police
setting up Tampa office they got an
office out on the west coast somewhere
and they're hunting down genuine people
from January 6. and and I'm not talking
about people who are violent and
fighting with cops because you Riot you
go to jail
there's one guy who's been locked up two
and a half years without any charges
and he was told if you say Trump made
you do it we'll let you go right now and
he said no really yep wow and that's not
the only case like that there's a photo
that just came out of a guy who is it
yeah me or where's he at DC prison I
don't know
let's pull it up uh let's see Bop
inmates for that one I have to ask uh
Matt Brainerd okay yeah all we need is
his name and his uh last name first name
and then his approximate age and we
could pull it up on blp we had a podcast
with somebody that spoke about Myron I
forgot who it was
um January 6. I forgot who was I spoke
about people being locked up
oh look at this fed's dispute story
behind viral photos allegedly debating
January 6 prisoner abuse so let's see
this was Tom fitton disturbing photos
leaked of January 6 prisoner abuse
tortured five months in isolation in a
closet room with a light on and a bucket
for a toilet
so uh the Gateway pundit adds on to it
claiming it and they're saying that the
uh
the FED said that he had nine prior
convictions terroristic threats he had
an assault conviction that has nothing
to do with January 6. okay so they're
not disputed they're saying he's a
criminal
okay
but the thing is a Litany of oh okay all
right it was a Litany of charges related
to January 6. but he was a bad guy so
the photos are real I guess as for the
other guy who's locked up you have to
ask me at Brainerd because I'm just you
know to be fair okay I'll I defer to him
okay I think it was Matt brainer who
talked about talk to us about that
because we could look it up if Anton
would have his name
the guys who actually focus a lot more
on the January 6th stuff than I do to be
completely honest okay so then I'll walk
it back and just say this sure I met a
woman recently she said that she's
getting probably 16 months because an
hour later after people had already left
she walked over and they there's no
barricades there's no signs there's
nothing and they walked up to the
building where the doors are open
nothing's good they don't see anybody
they see people walk around they walk in
look around six minutes in total they
walk out and they leave next thing they
know they're called insurrectionists and
they're gonna go to prison wow and they
were like but we didn't even like we're
just walking around we're not even not
even there for this and they're like
don't matter
so you've got that going on my point is
this
what happens when meanwhile we won't
prosecute antifa people oh for sure
Trump gets convicted nobody believes it
Trump gets removed from even a single
state the entire election
will be viewed as illegitimate and
already 2016 was called illegitimate by
democrats 2020 was illegitimated by
Republicans what do you think happens
when they outright just say Trump's off
the ballot Roseanne Barr came on the
show and said there won't be an election
and Michael malice said I'll bet you
money that's not true I said let's
clarify
by election do you mean a typical
election as we know it debate night then
everyone goes and casts their boats on
Election Day then they tell all the
numbers and then we say who won is that
an election
do you mean they Joe Biden will come out
and say I hereby decree there is no
election in bang a gavel or are you
saying Trump will be removed and no one
will think that what is actually
happening is an election like some
facade of election occurs but it's not
legitimately because Trump has already
been removed and so there's no way he
can win and Biden is a foregone
conclusion in which case people say
there was no election yeah and then
you've got half the country or more
slightly more actually because
Independents will probably agree not all
of them
that an election never occurred unless
Donald Trump is allowed to run and
unless he is on all of the states and we
run it like normal
to be fair even then people still won't
believe it but unless that happens
anything that puts a wrench in the
spokes Michigan removes Trump's name
they say oh he's in Georgia removes his
name one state then you're gonna have
half the country say through the states
have the authority to remove his name
from the ballot so under the argument
that they're making for they did it they
did it to a guy they did it to a guy
named Coy Griffin in New Mexico
that he was at January 6 and they said
as an insurrectionist under the 14th
Amendment he is disqualified from
holding office and they remove them
wow that that was their that their their
trial balloon now with Donald Trump they
want to do the same thing but that was
under state law federal okay they use
the 14th Amendment to justify okay so
because the 14th Amendment says anyone
who's waged Insurrection the reason they
keep saying Insurrection is because of
the 14th Amendment yep which basically
says anyone who wages Insurrection
against the US is ineligible blah blah
yep
if Trump is Trump's name is taken off
even one state
you will have a lot you'll have half
this country saying we never had a 2024
election yeah yeah
it's like North Korea at that point they
just say it's North Korea oh yeah the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea
had an election and Kim Jong-un got 99.9
of the votes again and then the other
guy who ran against them just goes oh
well you know everyone loves him yeah
and then afterwards they walk back say
here's your paycheck keep your mouth
shut yeah and my problem with this too
is like if you're gonna go ahead and go
after Trump for these charges then you
got to look at the bidens as well man I
mean dudes receiving Millions from China
his son's involved in some of the
nefarious activity
um everyone has their dirt so it's like
okay if you're gonna go ahead and go
after politicians cool go after all of
them yeah they never do then they never
do that's the problem and that's I think
a lot this I feel the same way about the
media like uh as much as we hate the
media and no matter how much you hate
the media you should probably hate them
more in most cases they would feel less
bad if they even made a half of an
attempt to be as willing to go against
people on their own side to to feign
some sense of legitimacy and honesty in
the reporting right if they were willing
to report on Joe Biden's or even Hunter
Biden's incidents half as much as
they're willing to talk about Trump you
could at least feign some sense of
objectivity from the media the same with
the government if they were willing to
go as much against Hunter and Joe not
offer sweetheart deals to Hunter and
actually seem like you were trying to
hold what do they always say speak truth
to power if you were actually trying to
hold power accountable maybe people
might buy it more but they don't because
they understand at least the ones who
are politically aware and Pecos pay
close attention understand that they're
not going to do that because they never
do and this is why mainstream media is
dying you know you guys this is why guys
like you are so important right
alternative media right you guys Joe
Rogan Etc like this is why people are
tuning in to other platforms to go ahead
and get their news I mean CNN MSNBC
these guys are dying the last time they
had as many views as well when Trump was
on the CNN Town Hall like he brought
them a bunch of views they're dying bro
because everyone knows those BS but this
brings up another issue though so
imagine alternate media right we have a
pretty much like free speech so to so to
say however they come after us what's
next because once again Trump is being
you know sorry kind of like put on the
state because he's the establishment
What About Us
media personalities are next 100 so yeah
well James O'Keefe is under
investigation in New York
and what I was saying was after after
they go for lawyers the next people are
going to be members of the media who are
in communication with Donald Trump and
then who publicly advocated for some
kind of action on January 6th yeah now
Jamesville keeps under investigation
that's more of a general they're
targeting their political opponents
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time